is a nurse in a school middle school
in uh connecticut
who was just suspended after she
revealed that one of her 11 year old
students was being put on puberty
blockers
against the parents
will
she said there was an 11 year old
student
on puberty blockers and that other
students
identified as non-binary so neither male
nor female without their parents being
informed this woman's name is kathleen
cadaford 77 years old was suspended from
the hartford public schools after
exposing this her exact words
as a public school nurse i have an 11
year old female student on puberty
blockers a dozen identifying as
non-binary all but two keeping this as a
secret from their parents with the help
of teachers social workers and the
school administration teachers and
social workers are spending 37.5 hours a
week influencing our children not
necessarily teaching our children what
you think is being taught she went on to
say children are introduced to this
confusion in kindergarten by the school
social worker who teaches teaches quote
unquote social and emotional regulation
and school
expectations
that's happening in the hartford public
schools are you a resident of hartford
are you a taxpayer in hartford or in
connecticut you should probably call up
your school board you should probably
call up your members of congress your
state representatives and your governor
and say that you don't want this crap in
their schools
if it's possible to bring suit if you're
a parent for instance in this district
and it's possible to bring a lawsuit
against the school district you most
certainly should you should probably
name specific administrators the
principal the superintendent you need to
hit them where it hurts which is the
purse which is the budget which is the
money which is their power
that's where you've got to hit them this
woman deserves an award kathleen
cadaford give her the michael knowles
show award for
professional courage so often people
write into the show they say michael how
do i speak up at my office without
suffering any repercussions michael how
do i speak up in the classroom without
getting a worse grade
you can everything in this life has
costs and this woman is standing up for
what is right
in an example of something that is so
clearly right preventing little kids
from being sexually mutilated by
perverts and idiots and radicals in
their elementary and middle schools
she's standing up for something that's
totally right and she's going to suffer
professional consequences she's already
been suspended she's probably going to
be fired doesn't matter she stood up for
what's right
i'm not saying you've got to go out
there and destroy your job you need to
be wise as a serpent and innocent as a
dove but we've got to push back the vast
majority of americans don't think that
11 year olds should be trans against
their parents will okay the vast major
the majority of democrats don't don't
think that that should happen
but the sickos who who are in power
right now the the corrupt
stupid
people who are in the really sub-par
people who are running the show right
now
all do believe that and and we still
have some political power in this
country and we've got to say no
i'm glad you like that clip now
subscribe ring the bell get
notifications head on over to apple
podcasts or spotify or stitcher or
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael noll show leave
a 5 star review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you